premier ministre tsipras jean-françois
encore une fois pris la parole et il a
tenu à expliquer sa stratégie aux grecs
parce qu'ils joueront quand même oui
c'est des jeux gros alexis type s il est
engagé depuis un bon moment dans un bras
de fer avec les créanciers de la grèce
et puis tout d'un coup il sort seul
apple a de son chapeau un référendum sur
un objectif est clair il l'a dit ce soir
à la télévision c'est d'essayer de
changer le rapport de force dans ces
négociations avec l'europe avec le fonds
monétaire international et pour sabah il
a besoin d'un appui massif des grecs il
a besoin d'un nom sans équivoque au
référendum pour pouvoir ensuite
retourner à la table des négociations
pour essayer d'obtenir des conditions
moins contraignante c'est son plan et ça
ça paraît risqué parce que le pays est
aujourd'hui très très divisée il ya une
très grosse majorité de grecs qui
souhaite aujourd'hui continuer de faire
partie d'europe qui continue souhaite
continuer d'utiliser l'euro donc cette
incertitude sur l'avenir du pays se
risquerait de devoir abandonner l'euro
baisse les inquiète et alexis tsipras a
donc ce soir à essayer de les rassurer
en leur disant que l'europe avait au
moins autant à perdre que la grèce d'une
sortie de la grèce de la zone euro l'a
dit que l'europe bleus fait vraiment
tout fait pour essayer de convaincre les
indécis de voter massivement non au
référendum la même mis sa démission dans
la balance si jamais le oui devait
l'emporter
je propose de l'écouter tu n'as pas de
stade au chômage a progressé history
neige mais ce qui est bien et auditeurs
pour sa cheville thomas mich koschmider
fall son action affiche une affaire
rooney kaka qui a dessiné un tricot son
époux maurice américaine texane a big
thing et tentera de se racheter le grec
sur le plan des européens et surtout sur
les mesures d'austérité qui
l'accompagnent est prévu de l'heure
le 5 juillet prochain jean-françois
merci tokyo va maintenant gerald bonsoir
on est vraiment dans l'inconnu alors est
ce que la grèce peut sortir de la zone
euro sortent trop de dommages c'est
l'inconnu ce que dit ce que disent les
créanciers européens c'est que nous
sommes dans une situation où la zone
euro est beaucoup plus solide qu'en 2010
l'espagne l'italie le portugal sont
revenus sur leur ait ça va mieux bien
que l'austérité a fait mal et qui a
encore des problèmes économiques mais la
situation s'est améliorée la banque
centrale européenne dit aujourd'hui on
peut intervenir dans les marchés aux
besoins si ça devient nécessaire avec de
l'injection de plusieurs milliards dans
les marchés c'est ce que disent les
européens d'un côté les grecs mise tout
sur le référendum
on sent que les deux préparent un
divorce mais en même temps on est quand
même assez éloignée du divorce on n'a
jamais été aussi près de ce divorce mais
a quand même une bonne distance pour y
arriver pour la simple et bonne raison
est ce que la grèce peut se relancer
avec une nouvelle devise le retour de la
drachme par exemple et en retour est ce
que la zone euro peut résister à la
sortie d'un pays ce sont des questions
qui demeurent difficiles les marchés en
tout cas expriment leur inquiétude n'est
pas de panique mais pas de panique c'est
ça qui est importante de l'inquiétude
avec des reculs de 3 5% en europe de
deux pour cent à toronto et à new york
mais regardez l'euro en progression
aujourd'hui de 0 7%
parce qu'on est convaincu de la solidité
de la zone euro mais à toronto tsx en
recul de faire de façon importante quand
même 300 points 350 points pour le dow
jones et notre dollar canadien qui était
en baisse aujourd'hui face à l'euro
alors ensuite tout ça merci beaucoup
gerald ward et pour mieux comprendre
comment la grèce en est arrivé là je
vous invite à consulter notre dossier
web à l'adresse que vous voyez à l'écran